[Musique]
c'est en fait à 16h fait c'est fait
l'amour première fois que l'âge 16 ans
[Musique]
et sinon pourquoi 15 ans alors ça s'est
passé
première fois non un fois pas mal
d'enfants
j'en tombe avait toujours dit ouais ça
l'amour c'est important la première fois
et tout je me suis dis pas pour moi
j'achète avec un mec que je connaissais
pratiquement pas puis revenant sur ma
page peut plus payer longtemps que vous
avez des rations succès les défis
ouais
ouais c'est normal parce que qu'ils on
est tous plus on est pauvre c'est pas
riche ici ils ont c'est même assez
prolétaires sur les bornes
on arrive vachement tôt là-dessus partir
d'un certain âge tu peux a même ramené
une besace chez toi tu peux faire ce que
tu veux mais quand tu es plus jeune mon
faut que tu ailles dans une cave où tu
te plantes
moi je veux ça m'est arrivé de me faire
gauler par des flics sur la plage ou des
conneries comme ça l'était crs avec les
jantes quote tu peux tu peux la vivre à
partir d'un certain âge quad qu'en
tapant dans un appartement ou quand les
parents acceptent plus ou moins parce
que tu es majeur au patio vous discutez
avec toi mais sinon quand les plus
jeunes c'est vachement difficile ça se
passe toujours dans les endroits plus ou
moins c'est assez plus ou moins
dégueulasse mois précédents montrent ya
ben gourion où n'importe où dans quand
que tu trouves quoi vite fait comme ça
on se régale non c'est vrai mais j'ai
pas vraiment à leur vie ça s'est fait
comme ça
j'avais même pas envie ça s'est fait
tout seul
ma vie tu vois c'est important d'agir
vouloir que la croix
tu connaissais bien le garçon avec qui
tu as fais l'amour la foi non c'est pas
bien c'est pareil tout est pensé en vie
je me disais ça durera c'est bien tout
j'essayais qui se bat plus la peur est
la peur tu avais peur avant dans un
séchage et plus
je suis bien caché que cette vie en
général
pour les débuts à tête des problèmes si
secret c'est normal cheikh magic en ch
penneteau s'est pas contenté je sais pas
je pense pas avoir eu de problèmes
physiques
7 quel ordre
le moral n'y était pas quoi non c'est
pas que mara n'y était pas mais sinon
ciel demande ritro le même
ouais c'est peut-être ça remarque je
vais dans des peaux jeunes c'est trop
jeune
je
des pommes besoin de têtes de tant de
désirs et étrangers est-ce que autour de
vous il ya beaucoup de filles qui agace
[Musique]
un peu plus jeunes qui commencent que
les jeunes non moi j'ai commencé chez
les comptes déjà pas mal de choses sont
du sud est dont discute entre copains
entre copines et toulouse c'était pas
pareil je commençais vraiment à jour
beaucoup de choses hein moi non ça le
franc comorien mars et peut-être aussi
ça qui m'a pas plu la première fois ce
que j'allais pas quoi faire de mariage
était paumé rien à faire ma mère amont
par les pales même maintenant je sais
pas je dirais la moitié de ce que je
vous dis là elle ce choix le malade elle
m'en parlait pas bon ben maintenant
depuis je faire pour leur stage en parle
tout le temps et ça me gêne pas du tout
est-ce que vous changez un garçon au nom
pas moi
si c'est bondé que charles quint tipping
clair tout et puis après je me lasse je
passe je recherche beaucoup d'affection
je recharge trop chez un versant et je
trouve pas j'ai pas encore trouvé tout
ce que je voulais ici c'est la grosse
rigolade
il ya une fille qui s'amène tout le
monde voilà tout le monde va là se
mettent à la draguer
et tous puis a justement le problème des
sentiments tout le monde a peur de
révéler ses sentiments parce que c'est
une question mais veulent pas jouer au
dur mais veulent ça c'est pas bien
vis-à-vis des autres de dire à une fille
oui tu me plais très jolie shy'm sortir
avec toi on va carrément lui dire sortir
avec elle il va coucher avec elle depuis
une fausse sera fini il dira de partir
que c'est fini même avec des moments
pour rigoler ghetto injurieux vous
paraît bien de vivre et puis d'en créer
pas mal de temps les gens maintenant des
relations sexuelles avec des garçons
bien j'aime bien moi je suis engagé
parce que c'est à dire qu'une fois qu'on
commence après ça va devenir un besoin
quoi c'est ça que j'ai nature parce que
je sais pas j'ai parti sadi a besoin ça
pue de la joie quoi facile mais après on
dirat bombe après tout c'est a besoin
j'avais gens n'éprouvent pas de la joie
quoi c'est pas du besoin c'est naturel
les filles sont désemparés collègues au
point de vue justement par les points du
point de vue par les copains de langage
et au point de vue réaction une fille je
vais lui dire voilà tu es mignonne
tu me plaît j'ai pas envie de sortir
avec moi j'ai simplement vu discuter
avec toi te prendre dans mes bras quoi
puis la fille va me regarder
déjà c'est déjà des idées à part si elle
va me regarder plus jamais dire la suite
de ma gueule avait rigolé quoi donc il
faut d'abord que je tâte le terrain que
je commence à discuter avec la fille et
après on peut éventuellement commence à
discuter sérieusement à son moi pour moi
l'amour c'est beau
moi je trouve ça c'est très beau la
montre hasan en effet pour on est né
pour ça tranche ça a une famille
histoire à des enfants
je trouve ça très beau pour toi l'amour
c'est on va récupérer les enfants et
pour toi aussi je rêve de faire un foyer
avant je me résultat je me marierai pas
jeunes et puis je crois que j'ai
tellement envie d'avoir un foyer à moi
des enfants pas lui avoir un foyer en
quelque sorte
une femme compte tête des enfants mais
vraiment libres parce que j'ai vite eu
un certain temps
quand ils voudraient bien moins pouvoir
et le fric
c'est vrai pour être frais qui ont merdé
le maximum d j'emmerde perdait des gens
vers les flics tout ça ce conte fin de
compte ils ont il ya huit ans pas mal de
trucs qu'ils ont tort et tabac c'est
tout mais c'est des trucs comme ça
j'avais du fric tu peux les faire chez
ces mecs là alors avoir un maximum de
fric pour ça je compte ce serait bien on
va faire des trucs intéressants et ta
vie sexuelle en face à vannes je pense à
sa charge
[Musique]